pokemon
you've gotta catch em all as the old
slogan goes
but what do you do once you have caught
them all
explore other interests
better yourself through learning
don't be ridiculous what you should do
is play other games that are sort of
similar to pokemon
and boy do we have you covered on that
front with a wide array of games that
hit the spot for pokemon fans
not all of these recommendations follow
the pokemon formula but they all capture
some piece of what makes pokemon such an
enduring sensation
check out our list and shout i choose
you
[Music]
coramon coramon is decidedly retro with
a pixel-based art style that looks to
emulate the earliest days of the pokemon
series it's one of the most faithful
pokemon likes around letting you collect
train and battle more than 100 creatures
with elemental skills with that
framework it does have some unique
twists like a stamina system that
defines your combat actions and a
flexible difficulty system that lets you
customize the game to your own comfort
level this includes an easy mode that
lets you just experience the story and
even a randomizer feature to mix up your
experience if you like the core ideas of
pokemon but want to see it rift on this
is a good pick
chocobo mystery dungeon everybody
this cutesy classically styled roguelike
starring the final fantasy mascot may
not immediately seem pokemon light and
in many ways it isn't but what it lacks
in specific mechanics it makes up for in
that same collecting spirit as chocobo
explores dungeons they'll find tons of
other notable final fantasy monsters and
creatures and bring them aboard as
buddies hence the name everybody half
the fun of pokemon is finding the
variety of creatures to recruit into
your party and chocobo mystery dungeon
everybody scratches that same itch with
the familiar faces of final fantasy
[Music]
nino cooney wrath of the white witch
nino kuni has become a franchise in its
own right but whereas the sequel and
mobile game are more styled as action
rpgs the first game released in the west
is very clearly inspired by the pokemon
series the combat system revolves around
capturing and taming a host of creatures
called familiars and then using them to
battle with other creatures while the
monster designs are not quite as
imaginative and varied as pokemon the
studio ghibli inspired art style and
dreamlike story are a captivating change
of pace and while the languid pace of
the game may have been hard to play on
its original playstation 3 release it's
been ported to just about everything
including nintendo switch just in case
you prefer your pokemon likes to be
portable
ooblets
ubletz is not entirely pokemon like
given its eccentric mixture of genres
and influences but somewhere in this
quirky blend is definitely some pokemon
dna in oublets you capture and do battle
with a variety of little captured
creatures the pool is smaller than a
pokemon game but they're differentiated
well and the game isn't intending to
blow you away with sheer variety instead
each one feels like a sweet little cozy
creation with names like dumburb and
wiggle whip
and rather than a typical one-on-one
pokemon battle
your creatures take part in non-violent
dance battles
that sense of infectious goofiness
permeates the whole experience giving it
a friendly feel and once you've captured
your creatures you can assign them to
help with small tasks or to tend to your
growing garden where you harvest food
for sale or other ooblets to add to your
collection
[Music]
monster crown monster crown is another
relatively faithful pokemon like game
but it's made for pokemon fans who have
grown into adults the story and creature
designs are darker than a traditional
pokemon game and the cute pixelated art
belies some fairly serious themes the
traditional monster collecting hooks are
still there though with more than 200
creatures to collect and evolve you can
even battle and trade online
[Music]
monster hunter stories and stories too
the monster hunter series isn't very
pokemon like at all considering in
pokemon they aren't known for skinning
and wearing the creatures
the more family-friendly spin-off
monster hunter stories though is much
more about raising and forming bonds
with the creatures in a more traditional
rpg structure mechanically the battle
system works very differently than a
traditional pokemon game with a slightly
more action-oriented structure and
different elemental structure for
weaknesses but it scratches the itch of
collecting monsters especially if you
have an affinity for monster hunter
designs who doesn't want to befriend a
rathalos both monster hunter stories
games are solid but monster hunter
stories 2 is better in almost every way
and doesn't require much knowledge of
the first game
[Music]
monster sanctuary
and now for something completely
different
monster sanctuary doesn't resemble
pokemon mechanically at all it's much
more of a traditional platforming action
side scroller but it does fulfill the
fantasy of taming wild beasts and using
them to traverse the world in a way
that's much more active than pokemon as
you build your array of beasts and level
them up you can use them in combat to
reach new heights and to ride on it's as
if the core concepts of pokemon were
interpreted in a completely different
way which is a very neat trick if you're
up for something unique
[Music]
nexomon and nexomon extinction
nexomon is another traditional pokemon
like with a bright colorful art style
and a huge wealth of 300 or so monsters
to collect and battle
this one mixes in some light resource
collecting and crafting with elemental
shards and the art style is very anime
inspired nexum on extinction the more
recent sequel throws you right into the
action with massive dragon tyrants
wreaking havoc but it's still very easy
to jump into the tamers guild and get
started and if you've always wanted more
starter options neximon makes a point of
giving you tons to choose from instead
of just the traditional fire grass water
trinity both games are available on
nintendo switch
[Music]
temtem
if you're at all interested in pokemon
likes you've almost definitely already
heard of temtem which has been in early
access since 2020. this is probably the
highest profile of all the games built
to take on the mega franchise indie
studio crema is aiming to build the
monster collecting mmo that pokemon fans
have been waiting for and all
indications from the early access
version are that it's pretty successful
at it now it's preparing for a full
version 1.0 launch in september for
consoles and pc and crema still has a
road map of continued support going
forward while lots of these games are
loving homages temtem is aiming to take
on the king
[Music]
world of final fantasy maxima
world of final fantasy is a cute chibi
rpg with a unique monster stacking
mechanic each character has its own size
class and you can manage the combat by
piling them on top of each other that
may not sound very pokemon like but like
chocobo's mystery dungeon square enix
makes the most of its long history of
iconic monster designs
you might do battle with a mughal
behemoth carbuncle and a little adorable
sephiroth all in different positions the
mechanic plays into the unique battle
system for something unlike anything
else but great for scratching that
collecting itch with creature designs
you already know and love
so there you have it an extensive list
of what to play when you can't play any
more pokemon i am a huge fan of studio
ghibli and definitely want to check out
nino cooney just to be able to virtually
inhabit one of their fantastic worlds
let us know in the comments what your
favorite non-pokemon pokemon game is
catch you next time here at gamespot
[Music]
you